unacceptable places to take a woman on a
first date going viral on the social
media platform X Formerly Known of
course as Twitter yeah it's leaving men
stumped on where else they should take
the woman the first six places are
popular restaurant franchise chains like
Applebees chilies I want my baby back
Olive Garden and the Cheesecake Factory
okay first of all Olive Garden yeah all
you can eat bread sticks salad soup I
mean that's a value Megan by the way
producer who made this is this just
going viral is it like on Reddit or
something in okay so women weigh in
someone somewhere pulled some women
somewhere and came up with a list that
these women say they do not want to be
taken on for a first date and that list
is topped by The Cheesecake Factory it
also includes Applebees chilies Chipotle
Olive Garden the movies Buffalo Wild
Wings Red Lobster Waffle House fast food
the gym bowling buffets nightclubs hook
hookah bar sporting events coffee shop
basically you should not take a woman to
any known location on Earth on a first
date